Her freak bitches.
What does Michael Phelps listened to who might be down 10
he doesn't give a fuck.
That is weird,
but the,
I think you just got to be that guy.
If you want to be that good,
who else is as good as him?
Nobody ever.
Right.
Who else has that intense?
Nobody.
He takes it all to the next level.
God Damn crazy people out there winning gold medals.
It's pretty fucking impressive.
Smokes a lot of weed.
I hear.
Yeah.
[inaudible] did you hear about the DEA this morning?
That really pissed me off.
They decided not to reclassify marijuana weight.
So they're keeping it in the same category as heroin.
Yeah.
Of stuff.
They decided that it has no medical benefits.
Now how?
Why can't we
take him to one of these kids that have seizures and just go here,
watch,
see seizure now see no seizure.
Okay.
Shut the fuck up.
You know,
common sense knows common sensor,
right?
Yeah.
I mean that's,
that's definitely evidence.
But I mean there's many,
many cases of that.
That is evidence that there's this test being done on these children in the real
world and it's working.
I mean,
whether or not it's scientific,
you know,
double blind,
placebo controlled evidence.
No,
but there's plenty of evidence about the medicinal benefits of cannabis.
There's a plenty of it.
There's plenty,
there's,
there's all sorts of data that seems to indicate that it has some sort of a role
in reducing tumors.
It can,
it definitely helps people with anxiety.
There's a,
there's a lot of factors that it does that.
Like,
you know,
when Neil Brennan was on,
he was talking about antidepressants and he was like,
they don't exactly know how they work.
And that's a really good point.
But they sell fucking ton of different kinds of antidepressants.
They know how cannabis works.
They know that there's canaveroid receptors in the human mind,
meaning the human brain is designed or grew up or developed alongside cannabis.
It knows what to do with it.
So when you take marijuana,
your body knows what it is.
Your body even produces some sort of cannabinoid response when you run.
That's part of what you're getting in the runner's high.
They say it's similar.
Is that correct?
I think that's correct.
How is this a true statement that they add in there that they don't know the
drug's chemistry is not known or reproducible?
I like that it says no current obsession accepted medical use because the drug's
chemistry is not reproducible,
not known,
and reproducible means what?
What does that mean?
Meaning drugs.
Chemistry is not known in reproducing.
Meaning they can't create it in a lab.
Yeah,
or they can't make two of the same.
Maybe they get,
you can't keep the same cue.
You can't clone the same person over and over again.
Every time you it's a different
maybe because when you get it as marijuana,
there's hundreds of different types of cannabinoids apparently,
and you're not just getting THC.
You're getting all kinds of other groovy shit in there to create a fee.
Yeah.
I think there's a ton of different types of cannabinoids.
Let's go download a little fucking information whole young Jamie.
How many things,
I'm going to guess.
There's a hundred different types of cannabinoids.
What do you think?
I would guess over a thousand.
Ooh,
Jesus Christ.
I also think it's 12 hours to the Pentagon.
85 cannabis contains at least 85 types of cannabinoids.
Many,
which have documented medical value.
That was 2014 they're probably found new ones,
bitch.
Okay.
Now there's only over 480 natural components found in the cannabis sativa plant.
Okay,
there you go.
So that's different.
So it's 480 natural components.
So 113 different cannabinoids says one in wicken in Wikipedia.
So you know it's real.
Um,
scroll down.
One more.
The one that,
this is how many different cannabinoids?
That's right.
64.
Yeah,
see,
so it,
so it varies.
The answers vary depending on studying year.
This is the most recent one,
right?
This is 2015 claim.
Going back to the marijuana thing with the DEA,
they had that happen.
They had to read or do that because the governor got so many sign petitions or
assigned names that it forced them to have to reclassify the marijuana.
I didn't know what governor,
but whoever it was,
you know,
if they,
uh,
they acquiesce to the demands of the Internet.
Right.
We definitely didn't do enough then.
So,
so if chatting more ramped up in that and they say that they couldn't clap,
reclassified,
they had to keep it the same because they couldn't find any health benefits from
it.
Right.
So what happens if that same governor gets all the signatures to reclassify
cigarettes or alcohol,
what would the da has to say then for the health benefits of those two?
Would they have to reclassify it as illegal?
It's a very good point.
Let's try it.
See what happens.
I would love to see what happens.
It's a very good point.
And here's another really good point.
They,
they're classifying it in schedule one cause that's where it's been.
And because they're,
they claim there's no known medical use or it can't be reproducible,
whatever the fuck that means,
you can grow it dummy.
You can get clones and grill it.
Of course it's three Bruceville.
It's just reproducible as a plant.
So what they're saying is it trying to classify it as a drug?
What they're almost admitting themselves.
If,
if what we're thinking is true.
If what they're saying is that you can't,
it's not reproducible because it's not a chemical that you can break down into a
pill.
If that's what they're saying,
like you can't standardize it because it's too wild and it's free and it's
growing.
That's almost a perfect example.
The fact that you're,
you're not,
you're,
it shouldn't be in a position where you're controlling a plant.
You shouldn't have be in a position where you're regulating nature,
but that's,
so you're almost admitting it yourself.
It's a repeat.
It's not reproducible.
Okay.
If that's what you're saying,
then you're saying it's not a drug.
Okay,
so,
but it has a psychoactive effect.
Okay.
Now you have to prove that psychoactive effect is dangerous.
Go ahead.
There's nothing that's the real problem.
The real problem is classified in the category of the most dangerous,
harmful drugs.
There's no evidence that that's should,
that should be correct.
There's no evidence.
So that's where the DEA is failing.
They're failing way more in that than they are.
And even not admitting that there's medical evidence.
Cause if you wanted to follow it to the strictest sense of the word,
what studies have been done that have absolutely been proven in,
you know,
a new modern form of like the,
the most current science.
What studies have been done that show the medical benefits of cannabis?
Well,
I'm not how many studies being done,
but it's because it's classified as schedule one,
it's a total catch 22 it's hard to get studies done because it's a schedule one.
And so you can't prove,
it shouldn't be a schedule one because there's not very many studies.
But there's a ton of studies that had been done by universities.
There's a ton of studies that have shown positive benefits.
If you want to go back into history,
even back into the Nixon administration,
they were running studies that they buried the results because the results
showed no harm.
They showed nothing.
They can't.
So when you follow just straight science,
there's no,
there's no evidence whatsoever.
It should be illegal.
That's the most important thing.
It's not the evidence of whether it should be legal.
That's like,
you know the whole thing about you're innocent until proven guilty.
It should be the same way about marijuana.
It should be that you can't just make it illegal and say it has to remain
illegal because we don't know what it can do because you do know what we can do.
You do.
You definitely know.
Why do you think of the millions of people like it?
Are they all crazy?
What's going on?
All these millions and millions of adults that live in America,
are they fucking crazy?
So what are you saying?
You're saying you're smarter than them.
Why don't you talk about it with somebody that knows what the fuck they're
talking about and you'll get buried.
Talk about it with a person who's like,
talk about it with like Todd McCormick commanded Todd McCormick.
Having a debate with one of these DEA guys about whether or not marijuana is
beneficial.
He survived cancer because of it mean a lot of people have,
we have friends that have kids that have autism.
They give their fucking kids this medical cannabis and all of a sudden they can
talk,
they relaxed,
they stop having seizures.
It's a massive benefit to a lot of people.
It relaxes people,
makes people feel good,
and we have a government agency in 2016 that ignores all of that and wants to
keep it in a category of some of the most harmful and dangerous drugs these
people have.
Like living in an episode of Hawaii five o the limit in the past,
they're like 1950s people.
And what they think they can do is like keep this,
this bureaucracy in this paperwork and he's classifications in in movement and
they can head off freedom because what they're trying to do is they're trying to
stop freedom.
And one of the reasons why the Trump's trying to stop freedom is because they
benefit from it.
They benefit from stopping it.
They have more agents.
If those eight,
if all of a sudden most drugs are legal,
what are those fucking thousands of Dea agents going to do?
They have,
they're protecting their own industry.
This is a natural thing that any organism does when it's threatened and if you
start making drugs legal and you start opening up that,
that conversation like who the fuck is any one adult to tell any other adult
what's good or bad for you?
When a lot of shit we do,
whether it's the food we eat,
the alcohol,
we drank the cigarettes,
we smoke the fucking sugar in our diet.
All these things are bad for us.
We all know that,
but we were afraid it was the government going to come in with a fucking machine
guns to stop you from eating a chocolate cake and smoking a cigarette.
Fuck that.
Right?
I think we all agree on that.
If they can't do that,
they shouldn't be able to stop you from smoking weed.
This is archaic.
This is like this is some ancient fucking vampire shit and they're clinging to
civilization.
They are totally irrelevant,
totally irrelevant.
Your decision should be made 100% on the facts that are available today.
You can go,
you could research all the facts about matter marijuana.
You find a few that make correlations between some sort of mental illnesses,
but those core,
most of the time,
at least according to experts that I've listened to talk about it,
the correlations of schizophrenia to marijuana use are directly in proportionate
with the quote,
the numbers of schizophrenia for any given population that there's always going
to be around 1% of the population that suffers from some type of schizophrenia
or severe mental distraction,
illness.
You know a bunch of different categories,
these little various mental diseases,
but it's always that number.
So if they smoked pot,
it's just a thousand people,
you know that smoked pot have schizophrenia.
Okay.
If there was the same amount of people and they didn't smoke pot,
it might be the same amount of schizophrenia x,
they might not even be connected.
But when you're talking about 300 million people and you say 30,000 people got
schizophrenia for marijuana,
are you fucking sure?
Are you really fucking sure or has it just 30,000 people have schizophrenia and
they also smoke marijuana cause this is the part,
this is a real problem with the way they present the data cause it's just like
you coming up to me or to Jamie and you saying that you've got new rules.
You as a 42 year old grown ass man,
you have new rules and we,
you don't want us drinking alcohol anymore.
You're going to,
you're going to come in and you've hired guards to keep us from smoking alcohol
or drinking alcohol.
It's the same thing.
If it's 50,000 people with some big building with three letters in the front of
it or whether it's one crazy fuck who wants to stop his neighbor from smoking
pot?
It's the same thing.
You're trying to stop someone from doing something that's not bad.
Like you can't do that.
You don't have any evidence that it's bad.
There should be a fuck load of evidence that it's bad and it should
be as much or worse than all the shit that you know is bad that you sell open
and make money from taxes,
alcohol,
which we both love.
I love.
But here's a great example of getting him.
I talk a lot.
They just research released a study that I think this week showing the like they
proved scientifically that a weed is better for sex and they not only did it for
pleasures,
but they also explained how when you have alcohol,
you a,
you cheat more,
you,
you do bad things,
you hook up with people he shouldn't do.
You don't use condoms.
Like do a lot of shit that lot of people change.
I'm on team boobs,
let's do this danger style.
But it's shit that is life changing.
Getting a girl pregnant that you hope met at a bar that looked hot last night.
You wake up and it's a dog.
You know,
like all the dog you talking about a woman and woman human.
How dare you?
No,
I'm fine.
Was that slut shaming about shits?
Actual dog.
Okay.